president trump's parent power
revolution
here he is last week in what i thought
was one of the most
important policy statements of his
presidency
if schools do not reopen the funding
should go to parents to send their
child to public private charter
religious or
home school of their choice the key word
being choice
if the school is closed the money should
follow the student
so the parents and families are in
control of their own decisions so we'd
like the money to go to the
parents of the student i've been
arguing for this for years here's what i
wrote in my book more human
the government school monopoly requires
standardization and a factory approach
we need a completely
open local marketplace for schools
teachers educational entrepreneurs
and groups of parents must be permitted
to set up schools
free of bureaucratic restrictions and
hassle today
it's becoming a reality all because the
teacher unions
and the democrats and the bureaucrats
and the rotten educational establishment
have overplayed their hand
as i put it in a tweet after last
sunday's show the government school
monopoly
is dying suicide thanks to teacher
unions
school boards refusing to give parents
what they want
micro schools homeschooling it's all
happening next step
federal school vouchers my school money
back
we've laid out the evidence week after
week the science
says reopen schools children are far
less likely to get the virus spread the
virus suffer from the virus
while they are suffering massively from
not being at school
but the exact same people who lecture us
about following the data
who call you a science denier if you
disagree with a single aspect of their
ever more extreme
environmental agenda well they are the
science denies now
keeping schools closed despite all the
evidence that it's not just
unnecessary for controlling the virus
but actively harmful to our children
now i try to be open-minded the
bureaucratic school closure brigade
they're just covering their
you-know-what right government officials
they're always
over cautious prattling on about safety
being their top priority
even though keeping kids away from
school is not safe it's dangerous
but when you see things like the united
teachers of los angeles
in their school closure demand adding
medicare for all
defunding the police and a moratorium on
charter schools
the oregon education association
demanding that
charter schools even be stopped from
offering distance learning
in north carolina a local affiliate of
the ncaa demanding
universal health care and income support
for illegal immigrants
what has any of this got to do with
slowing the spread of coronavirus
nothing the school closures are not
about health
they're about power a cynical trick to
boost the power
of probably the most destructive single
institution in america
the teacher unions and it's not just
cynical
it's corrupt the politicians caving to
the teacher unions on school closures
are just doing the bidding of their
donors more than 200 million dollars
over the last three decades and with the
democrats
the institutional corruption goes all
the way to the top
joe biden throughout his corrupt career
bought and paid for by the teacher
unions including
nearly 2 million dollars since 2018
from just one of them here's what the
unions
got in return you don't just have a
partner in the white house
you'll have an nda member in the white
house and if i'm not listening i'm going
to be sleeping alone in the lincoln
bedroom
no privately funded
charter school would receive or private
charts will receive a penny of federal
money
none in his platform
biden pledging to kill a washington dc
school
choice program that helps poor kids go
to college
over 90 percent of them black and
hispanic
biden's corrupt scheme to attack the
very schools
that help poor kids and black kids the
most
is racist and evil it alone makes him
unfit to be president well parents
they can see through all the bs they've
had enough and they're not
taking it anymore two weeks ago we
launched our campaign
if your child's school won't open this
fall demand
your money back so you can find an
alternative
it's your child it's your tax dollars
why should you pay for a service you're
not getting
that's my new campaign reopen schools or
give me
my school money back now
parents all across america are rising up
in this revolution
to smash the government school monopoly
last week jordan sekulow told us
that hundreds of families had contacted
the aclj about suing school closure
districts
here's that map as of friday over 1 000
people from 46 states and dc
if you want to join in go to aclj.org
forward slash help the scale and
pace of this is shocking to the
complacent education establishment
in this account shared by bethany mandel
within a 48-hour period
thousands of parents scrambled to online
communities to put together
homeschooling groups
there are reports of families teaming up
to recruit teachers
and form pandemic pods so their children
won't go more months without a real
education
of course the snooty elitist try to
pretend this is all about rich white
parents it's racist to want to educate
your kids now
apparently how disgusting for years
black parents have been in the vanguard
of the school choice movement
as thomas soule documents in his
brilliant new book charter schools on
their enemies
as he put it himself schools exist
for the education of children not to
provide ironclad jobs for teachers
billions of dollars in union dues for
teacher unions monopolies for
educational bureaucracies
a guaranteed market for teachers college
degrees or
a captive audience for indoctrinators
the left says poor parents can't handle
school
choice how patronizing one
of the most inspiring sights of my life
was seeing parents in one of the world's
worst
slums in lagos nigeria
get together to fund a low-cost private
school
paying just cents to send their kids
there because the local government
school was failing their kids
private schools for the poor is a
phenomenon sweeping the developing world
and now here in america the alternatives
to government schools are becoming more
and more affordable
there are many organizations ready to
help we'll put them out on social media
over the next few days because the cost
of these innovative alternatives is
falling all the time
a federal school voucher in the low
thousands of dollars
would enable millions of parents to
escape the clutches of the government
schools
and that's exactly what president trump
announced
this week he wanted in the relief bill
guess who's standing in the way of that
unbelievably
it's mitch mcconnell and steve mnuchin
right now planning to give 70 billion
dollars
to school bureaucrats including those
who won't even open schools
they think this is smart politics before
an election no
school boards don't vote parents do
give the money directly to them just
like the president
wants make it a red line for the next
relief bill let's get it done
let's put power in parents hands let's
put our children first
let's kill off for good the power of the
educational establishment the school's
bureaucracy
the teacher unions have all done so much
damage for so long
and back the parent power revolution